listos tiene grandes planes económicos
para reino unido al asumir el máximo
cargo del país como primera ministra
antes de ser nombrada como próxima líder
george había dicho a la bbc que se
pondría manos a la obra
si soy elegida como primera ministra en
el plazo de una semana me aseguraré de
que haya un anuncio sobre cómo vamos a
tratar el tema de las facturas de la
energía y del suministro a largo plazo
para poner este país en una situación
adecuada para el invierno
a 3 no explicado cómo piensa amortiguar
el golpe del aumento de los costes
energéticos
pero según los medios de comunicación
británicos la nueva líder del partido
conservador podría congelar las facturas
energéticas de los hogares y las
empresas en consonancia con la propuesta
presentada por el partido laborista el
mes pasado una congelación que costaría
hasta 100 mil millones de libras unos
115 mil millones de dólares la próxima
ocupante del número 10 de downing street
también dice que introducirá recortes
fiscales los críticos aseguran que sus
planes aumentarían la desigualdad según
el instituto de estudios fiscales la
política añadiría sólo siete como 66
libras cerca de 9 dólares a los
bolsillos de los hogares con menores
ingresos mientras que las rentas más
altas ganarían más de 1800 libras más de
2 mil dólares trust ha contraatacado
afirmando que es un error ver toda
política económica a través del lente de
la redistribución de la riqueza pero los
expertos dicen que los planes podrían
irritar a la ciudadanía los nuevos
votantes que boris johnson fue capaz de
ganar para el partido conservador en
2019 muchos de ellos con más bajos lo
que buscan no son recortes de impuestos
y un estado pequeño se espera que el
secretario de estado para negocios
energía y estrategia industrial caguas y
quart en que sea nombrado ministro de
hacienda él asegura que el nuevo
gobierno introducirá planes fiscalmente
responsables